I just had a fascinating experience I
was on a work trip and I was in a
country I'd never been to before
Thailand I was in Bangkok doing some
work there more on that later
um but it was fascinating and uh I sent
you a little message Mr Gourley yeah I
know you're a bond fan and at one point
I met the floating Market in uh in
Bangkok where you can get on a boat and
go from Market to Market and buy your
wares your souvenirs and then go on to
the next markets this really uh famous
venue I had forgotten this but someone
it might have been Aaron Blair was with
me because we always travel together as
lovers
and um that's true yeah so I don't have
to pay you also that's also right it's
just a relationship so I'll have
relationships with people just so I
don't have to pay them no they don't
want to exchange hands but a lot of
other stuff okay I do you do pay him yes
she will ever
um oh oh No One's Gonna voluntarily lay
with this old bag of bones so anyway
this took a I don't know what did you do
that no why did I do it he's the one
that said yes wait a minute now we're
really so here's the point yeah which is
blay mentioned oh this would make Gorly
jealous and before he even said anything
else I was elated because I didn't know
what blay was talking about but I was
immediately happy that there was a way
that you could be unhappy and he said
this is where they shot the bond a
famous sequence in the James Bond film
Man with the Golden Gun and then I
remembered oh right Roger Moore is
driving through the market and he's
being chased and I immediately
remembered that so I made a video and it
must have been like three in there or
four in the morning here in Los Angeles
it was Midday Bangkok and I sent it to
you and
um I hope you took that video in the
spirit in which it was meant well first
let me clear something up I'm not really
a James Bond fan oh oh James Bond oh my
God you're wearing a shirt that says
James Bond will return and second of all
you know we were talking about this
today
a lot of James Bond wait a minute you're
just wearing a James Bond shirt
underneath your sweatshirt and you
happen to be wearing that when we
brought this up that's true that's sick
you're a sick person you're a sick too I
feel better or worse about doing this
now I just feel like you need to you
shouldn't have a family oh
I think social Services should come by
and take both your child and your wife
away which they rarely do they usually
just take the child but at this point I
think they should take both away yeah um
all right so you're I didn't wow that
blows my mind that you that's right you
didn't know what I was gonna I mean I'm
not even gonna justify it never mind so
I sent you a video Yeah and how did you
feel when you got the video well do you
want to listen to it yeah let's play it
here I have it
hey Matt Conan here I am here at the
floating Market in Bangkok this is where
they shot that iconic scenes in uh man
with a golden gun and I know that this
is on your bucket list I just wanted you
to know I got here first
now the biggest issue I take
do you understand the meaning of the
word psych so were you or were you not
there
Oh you mean like it
you blew it I blew it oh so you mean
psych should have meant I fooled you I'm
not really there yeah
California well guess what no it does
still make sense because I don't think I
was at the exact look I think the exact
location was about a hundred yards away
this is a very Infamous scene in bond
history because Roger Moore is in a
little boat chasing a little Thai Boy
comes up to sell him something and he
face Palms him and shoves him in the
water what an I know yeah and
this is Roger Moore Roger Moore who's
typically the kind of friendly Bond
right he's the bond that used hairspray
and a lot of it yeah a lot of it yeah
yeah so yes that's I remember that scene
him shoving a little boy into the water
yeah but yeah I just wanted you to know
that I got there first you know what's
worse I've been to Thailand and I didn't
even get to see that really yeah well
did you know that yeah I just was tired
I'm tired it was so how tired do you
have to be to not go to a bond local you
know what the only thing that beats me
is heat I will if it's hot out and like
humid I don't want to go do it it was
record-setting heat when I was there and
I could tell because the Thai people I'd
be walking down the street and the Thai
people were walking up to me going Jesus
it's hot
this is freaking hot and I said like so
you're I'm a native yes I've lived here
my entire life good God and uh yeah did
you go to the pp Island no I know that
sounds like a setup to a joke but it's
that's well that's set up for a joke you
would do but uh how about Joe B Flats
nope didn't go there either okay that's
where the the beautiful like Islands
stick out of the water and that's from
the end of that movie
I did not go uh down to the islands no
did not go there uh shot almost
exclusively in and around uh Bangkok
which is fascinating it's a fascinating
Place loved it food was extraordinary
people are lovely and we shot some stuff
there that I think people are gonna
really like happy about that but I um
mostly have been battling I think I got
back two days ago I had no problem with
the flight from LA flew from LA to Hong
Kong and then to Thailand no jet lag
nothing just got Right to Work landed in
the morning got right to work and we
were there for about nine days then came
back Hong Kong to LA and my heart hasn't
functioned properly I have just been I
my body's completely screwed up
completely screwed up and my mind
doesn't work and I think I'm capable of
any crime right now I think that's
because when you get to Thailand you're
like oh it's time to shoot and then it's
like your adrenaline because you've seen
me an accident I've seen you it's not
like you're gonna be like I need a nap
first you're like let's get the camera
let's go but when you come back here
what you don't shoot anything there's
just a wife and a son oh and they're
like what's this all about you should
have their family taken away from them
they've called they've called Social
Services they're constantly calling
social services I don't I don't think it
has anything to do with the time change
or the flight I think it has to do with
the camera pointing at your feet
it is true I was doing all this stuff
that I can only do when a camera's
pointed at me I was doing all these
stunts and things that and people were
saying hey you're kind of old you
shouldn't be like I'm fine roll that
camera we just shot him in the chest and
he seems fine yeah shoot me again so we
get it from the other angle set me up to
use the word psych yeah teach me how to
use that word I will say we we did and
we put a picture out on social media
view kickboxing and it's more time
kickboxing and I should mention that
although it was covered it was
completely outside yes and every day we
would look at the temperature and it
would say 94. feels like a hundred and
eight yeah I'm not exaggerating that's
what it said and so with the humanities
because the humidity it's a hundred and
eight and it's a it's a wet we did a
shoot and I was just trying to get out
of the way and was out of breath and
sweating through my clothes you were
literally jumping and kicking yeah it
was insane yeah and I um I'm fueled by
uh a terrible hole in the middle of my
soul
that uh just Powers me on I know
um but uh no I did we that was really
fun uh we we did all the stuff that I
really enjoyed but uh it was I mean a
highlight was getting to a bond site
before you
um and now I'm determined to go and
visit all the bond sites I can it's
without you it's on without race no no
you got a lot to catch up on I've been
to a lot of them
um first of all I'm gonna hire a
cinematographer to study those scenes
and prove to you that you weren't in the
exact right place
I'm gonna spend a great deal of money
and then I am going to go to all the
exact correct places and I'll get the
permission of the Roger Moore estate
to examine all the documents necessary
remember he died on my birthday no I
don't remember that I remember I don't I
you leave my mind the minute I leave his
Studio I don't doubt that I don't doubt
that
remember he died on my well I only say
that not because I expect you to
remember that but because when I said
that before you hit me so hard you
really hit me over the head with that
fact yeah so I thought maybe it did make
an impression no okay great no I think
the way for him to be nice to you is if
you just came with a handheld a camera
oh man I think if you donated uh if you
were proven to be an exact perfect match
for my bone marrow and you saved my life
by going through an excruciating
procedure I would quickly forget about
it oh I would also never do that
no no you understand I would hire people
to hold you down and we would extract
the bone marrow using simple gardening
tools I I would then there's nothing you
can do about drink a lot of Drano that
would then Osmos ties into my mind as
bad as it is for your body really does
enhance bone marrow production really
yeah oh okay so got me there you Evil
Genius I say petting a cat
um all right well if you want to see a
bond site write in right in right in and
uh Gorly will tell you if he's been
there or not bye Psych